es ist eine wahre invasion sechs jahren
nach dem schweren seebeben an der
nordküste japans mit einem verheerenden
tsunami in folge passiert etwas extrem
ungewöhnliches an der pazifik küste
nordamerikas in japan starben damals
knapp 20.000 menschen im atomkraftwerk
fukushima kam es zum super-gau und jetzt
tausende teile wurden ins meer gespült
und liegt seitdem offensichtlich
verschiedenen lebewesen als floß und die
führen jetzt teilweise 7000 kilometer
entfernt an der westküste der usa zu
einer invasion welche lebewesen genau in
den vergangenen jahren auf plastik
flößen den pazifik überquert haben und
was das jetzt für konsequenzen hat
zusammengefasst also wie ist die lage in
nordamerika jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
die amerikanischen meeresbiologin und
biologen haben nicht schlecht gestaunt
als sie das zwölf meter lange doch
untersucht haben
das 2012 am strand von orion angespült
wurde genau wie auf vielen anderen
objekten haben sie darauf nämlich knapp
300 verschiedene spezies identifiziert
und zwar alle aus japan gereist sind sie
wohl auf den unzähligen objekten die
durch den tsunami 2011 in den
pazifischen ozean gespült worden sind
kleine plastikteile genauso aber auch
ganze schiffe oder teile von
industrieanlagen muscheln seepocken aber
auch größere tiere wie krebse und bürger
fische waren ihre passagiere und sie
haben die lange fahrt von japan bis an
den strand in oregon tatsächlich
überlebt das ist wirklich verblüffend zb
in wassergefüllten löchern der
trümmerteile und das kassel
viele der tiere haben die lange zeit auf
ihren flöten nicht nur überlebt nein sie
haben sich sogar vermehrt ein rekord
haben gleich zwei langzeit überlebende
gemacht sowohl die miesmuschel mit tilos
gallo provinzielles als auch die
seepocken mega balance rosa haben 7000
kilometer zurückgelegt in sechs jahren
und das lebendig zitat also wäre das
erste mal arten aus japan in euren
fanden waren wir geschockt wir hätten
nie gedacht dass diese organismen auf
dem offenen ozean so lange überleben
können das sagt einer der beteiligten
meeres ökologen john chapman von der
oregon state university
die meisten lebewesen kann wohl zwischen
2012 und 2014 an der amerikanischen
küste an aber auch noch in diesem jahr
ist das forschungsteam fündig geworden
und zwar auf trümmern
die bereits im jahr der großen tsunami
katastrophe 2011 ins meer gespült worden
waren und seitdem also unterwegs sein
die großteile der lebewesen nutzten die
plastikteile als hilfsmittel für ihre
überfahrt und das ist tatsächlich eine
wirkliche neue erkenntnis denn dass
organismen auf holzstücken oder anderen
natürlichen materialien durch das meer
schwimmen das war bereits bekannt so
erklärt man sich dass viele inseln durch
arten vom festland besiedelt worden sind
in diesem fall ist die langlebigkeit des
plastiks im wasser tatsächlich mal von
vorteil
zumindest für die passagiere denn anders
als holz verrottet es nicht nach kurzer
zeit und macht längere überfahrten
überhaupt erst möglich
dennoch ist die entdeckung aus oregon
wirklich überraschend denn bislang ging
man davon aus dass solch ein floß mitten
auf dem offenen meer einen mehr als
lebensfeindlichen ort darstellt vor
allem für diejenigen organismen die
sonst eher in küstennähe leben denn die
uv strahlung ist auf dem offenen ozean
viel stärker und zudem gibt es weniger
nahrung unklar ist bislang noch ob sich
diese organismen aus japan jetzt
langfristig in den usa
ob es sie sich gemütlich machen das
hängt laut aussage des forschungsteams
wohl davon ab ob genug individuen einer
art die lange überfahrt lebendig
überstanden haben denn dann könnten sie
sich in der neuen heimat verlieren die
beteiligten mehreren um und ökonomen
sind jedenfalls optimistisch zitat es
würde mich aber sehr wundern wenn das
keiner dieser organismen schaffen würde
das sagt chapman was das dann genau für
das ökosystem an den amerikanischen
küsten bedeutet kann man heute noch
nicht abschätzen falls sich die
neuankömmlinge zu stark ausbreiten
sollten könnte es passieren dass sie
heimische arten verdrängen fest steht
jedenfalls auch dass sich in zukunft
wohl immer mehr lebewesen auf diese art
und weise verbreiten werden
denn in unseren ozean treibt wie wir
wissen immer mehr plastikmüll also auch
biologisch findet die globalisierung
statt wenn er kein video zu diesem thema
nach zu allen themen anderen themen
verpassen wollte dann würden wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke sonst erfahrt ihr
nämlich nie von den neuen videos hier
bei pixum oder zumindest fast nehmen ja
hier geht es weiter mit riesiges
bienensterben europa spannendes video
wie immer hier und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran